security forces on high alert
the threat of another suspected bomb
causing panic in this neighborhood
officials say they believe a little
known as la mist group was behind the
carnage on Easter Sunday but with some
kind of link to what a cabinet spokesman
called an international network
suspicion has fallen on Islamic state or
al-qaeda this was a very sophisticated
attack it was coordinated multiple
locations synchronized very
sophisticated explosive devices we're
talking about one of the largest
terrorist attacks that has taken place
since 9/11 and a local outfit that's
been known for carrying out stunts like
defacing statues cannot suddenly go from
that to carrying out one of the biggest
attacks we've seen a document
circulating on social media reveals an
advanced warning was given to the Sri
Lankans
earlier this month from a foreign
intelligence agency of a possible attack
on churches it named the little-known
national to eath jamaat group the same
local group identified by the
authorities today it's not clear if any
action was taken on the tip-off raising
the possibility of a blame game over
possible intelligence blunders if
international links are proven the
carnage here in Sri Lanka could signal
the start of a new campaign of so-called
spectacular terrorist attacks around the
world security forces just earlier had
to come to the area behind me to defuse
a suspected car bomb the Sri Lankan
authorities are asking the international
community for help with the
investigation Britain has much
experience of Islamist terrorism such as
the London Bridge attacks and has
offered assistance such as with police
forensic or intelligence experts I've
met and spoken with the Prime Minister
and with ministers with senior officials
and I have assured them of the UK's
willingness to offer assistance as
useful for the
to have it Tom dependants kid depending
what is most useful to Sri Lanka and so
yes we're waiting for them to tell us
what they would find most useful some
two dozen people have already been
arrested all Sri Lankans
security forces are being granted
wartime powers to make further arrests
as they race to prevent further attacks
Deborah hain Sky News Colombo